so dreimal Pizza zum Mitnehmen war das
für sie ja genau
dreimal Pizza Hawaii richtig ja Pizza
dreimal
dreimal Pizza Hawaii schön oh haben sie
dann Kontrabass ja das ist ein
Kontrabass
entschuldigung wenn ich Fragen aber sind
sie Japaner oder Chinese ich bin
Chinesen
Kontrabass und die drei Pizza Hawaii
sind die für sie oder warten draußen
zufällig noch zwei Kollegen auf sie
richtig raten wir sind drei drei
Chinesen mit dem Kontrabass und was
machen sie so also bevor sie da in mein
Lokal reingekommen sind wir saßen auf
der Straße und erzählten uns was lasst
es mich raten und vorher so die Polizei
gekommen und die haben gesagt ja was ist
denn das und dann haben sie gesagt drei
Chinesen mit dem Kontrabass
auch was zum Essen bestellen Hallo
möchten Sie auch was zum Essen bestellen
nein nein danke ich bin nur sein Bruder
Bruder Jakob
der Bruder Jakob genau der Bruder Jakob
Bruder Jakob schläfst du noch schläfst
du noch
hörst du nicht die Glocke hörst du nicht
die Glocke ding dong dong ding dong dong
und und wer sind sie mein Name ist
butzemann
ja genau
na überarbeitet gestresst und mit den
Nerven am Ende
dann nehmen Sie mehr verdien mit
navalgien sind sie in 0,6 wieder auf
Zack
[Musik]
Entschuldigung mir ist ein Hänsel und
Gretel wo geht's hin zum Lebkuchenhaus
einfach die Straße runter und dann die
zweite Links
und sie sind wieder Herr der Lage